BAD COSPLAY.
>> THE INTERNET NO SHORTAGE OF
COSPLAY GALLERIES. THEY'RE HUGE
ON THE INTERNET.
HERE ARE SOME OF MY FAVORITE
EXAMPLES.
THAT'S KEVIN PEREIRA PEREIRA AND
I WHEN WE WORKED AT G4.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> ONE THING WONDER WOMAN DIDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY WE HAD TO WORRY
ABOUT HER BAG HANGING DOWN.
>> HIT US REALLY BAD COSPLAY
THAT WOULD GET NEGATIVE LIKES ON
FACEBOOK, IF THERE WERE SUCH A
THING.
SO 60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
GO.
>> GAVIN.
>> IRONING MAN.
>> POINTS.
BURNIE.
>> BLACK WIDOWS COUSIN REGULAR
JUST GRIEVING WIDOW.
>> POINTS.
GUS.
>> DONALD STERLING.
>> Chris: YES.
>> SUCH A BAD ONE. POINTS. GUS
AGAIN
>> ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER'S
HOUSEKEEPER.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS. BURNIE.
>> GUY WITH TOURRETS WHO KNOWS A
BUNCH OF GAME OF THRONES
SPOILERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> DISAPPOINTED JAPANESE
PARENTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
GAVIN.
>> QUEERIAN LANISTER
>> Chris: POINTS.
BURNIE.
>> NEIL PATRICK HITLER.
>> Chris: A LITTLE BIT OF A
MASHUP THERE.
POINTS.
BURNIE.
>> DRAGON BALLZ.